[Musique]
le gouvernement et du besoin de ce grand
débat qui a coûté 12 millions d'euros
qui a duré plusieurs mois de ce grand
débat pour savoir que les français
paient trop d'impôts
j'attends aujourd'hui les solutions les
réformes notamment les réformes
structurelles du gouvernement qui est
bien fort pour parler mais qui n'est
malheureusement pas à la hauteur pour
agir aujourd'hui les cibles de ce
gouvernement ce sont les retraités les
familles et les classes moyennes dit on
va taxer les plus riches et à l'arrivée
en attaque surtout les classes moyennes
pourquoi est-ce que je veux que ce soit
une baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu pour
tous parce que les principales victimes
de l'impôt sur le revenu c'est les
classes moyennes j'assume de dire stop
les seuils en france stop les usines à
gaz
stop les systèmes fiscaux qui sont
tellement compliquées qu'elles arrivent
et ya aucun impôt qui baisse il ya eu
beaucoup de mots ce matin mais ce que
les français sont en droit d'attendre
désormais ce sont des actes pekke rinne
et le maquereau est arrivé il a dépensé
plus d'argent en deux ans que françois
hollande en deux ans je n'en peux plus
de voir ce gouvernement essayait de
gagner du temps repoussé nos
propositions concrètes vous les
redistribuer de l'argent
commencez déjà par en prendre moins
quand on vous propose de baisser l'impôt
sur le revenu c'est du retour de pouvoir
d'achat
quand on dit qu'il faut revaloriser le
pouvoir d'achat des retraités qui ont
été les principales victimes de la
politique du gouvernement
c'est du pouvoir d'achat mais il va
falloir passer aux actes ça fait des
mois que ça dure là il est temps qu'il y
ait des véritables propositions et
notamment des véritables propositions
sur la fiscalité la fiscalité de l'impôt
sur le revenu qui est quand même l'impôt
qui est liée au travail
et bien sûr pour les retraités parce que
les retraités ont été les vaches à lait
de la politique d' emmanuel macron
surtout qu'il y a des petites retraites
qui malgré ce qu'avait dit monsieur
macro n'ont pas été épargnés qu'il faut
revaloriser au minimum de l'inflation
toutes les retraites
nous demandons la suppression de
l'augmentation de la csg
quand on crée l'incertitude sur un sujet
aussi important que les retraites qui le
travail que les gens ont fait toute leur
vie et la manière dont ils vont pouvoir
vivre les années qui leur est devant eux
ont produit une héparine de léser
on incite les français à ne pas
consommer à mettre de l'argent de côté
c'est très mauvais pour l'économie
et c'est aussi une forme d' indignés